public sénat
bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen à bruxelles cette
semaine lé en quête de cette émission
nous emmène en irlande c'est l'un des
deux états européens où l'avortement est
interdit mais le débat est relancé dans
le pays et tout de suite le cas de
chypre qui continuent à secouer toute
l'europe avec nos invités nous verrons
si nous pouvons laisser notre argent
dans les banques européennes
c'est l'histoire d'un petit territoire
deux bouts d'europe menacés par la
faillitte qui connaît chypre si ce n'est
pour ses plages et ses banques il faut
dire que le secteur bancaire chypriote
représente 900 % de son pib alors on
parle du père trophy bancaire
hypertrophie une jolie feinte pour ne
pas dire paradis fiscal
comment un paradis fiscal en plein coeur
de la zone euro vous plaisantez
pas vraiment
alors que faire pour sauver chypre une
fois de plus fmi bce eurogroupe ont
inventé un dispositif dont eux seuls ont
le secret taxer les dépôts bancaires
cafouillage ultimatum règlements de
compte et réunion de la dernière chance
le sauvetage dans l'urgence à une
nouvelle fois fait vaciller la zone euro
et pendant ce temps à nicosie en
attendant la sortie de crise on sent
comme un air de déjà vu dans les rues
chypriote
les manifestations se suivent et se
ressemblent banque clause économie en
panne entreprises fermées magasins
dévalisés
un air de graisse 1er d'espagne un air
de portugal alors
à tout sacrifier chypre
alors notre invité aujourd'hui et jean
paul gauzès bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député européen français vous êtes
membre du ppe est également membre de la
commission des affaires économiques et
monétaires ici au parlement européen
est-ce que lorsque le roux groupe a
décidé de prendre de l'argent sur les
comptes des chypriotes quel qu'il soit
est ce que l'eurogroupe n'a pas commis
là une erreur
quoique la grossière erreur a été la
façon dont les choses ont été
semble-t-il réfléchie est annoncé sur le
problème de fond on peut on peut poser à
se poser des questions mais il est clair
qu'il était vraiment détestable de
laisser entendre que c'était l'europe
qui prélevée sur les comptes des
particuliers alors qu'en réalité c'est
une proposition qui est faite à l'état
chypriote et le parlement chypriote
avait le dernier mot et on l'a bien vu
il a refusé pendant juste j'aimerais
comprendre en fait ce que vous dites
c'est que c'était acceptable de prendre
de l'argent sur des comptes entre
dealers où pouvaient se trouver oui
parce que fois qu'il ya deux choses il
faut pas confondre il ya la fortune
personnelle des gens l'épargné déposée
et puis les dépôts sens bancaire les
limitations dont tout le monde parle
cent mille euros c'est une limitation
c'est une protection c'est une garantie
dans le cas où la banque qui reçoit les
dépôts fait faillite là nous n'étions
pas dans un cas de faillite de la banque
avéré d'enfin dans le schéma qui était
prévu elles ont un véritable ça a évolué
mais dans le schéma qui était prévu à
réty s'agissait d'un impôt sur la
fortune prélever directement à la source
mais comme ça a été très mal présentés
évidemment chacun à penser qu'elle
c'était autre chose quelle que soit la
présentation qu'on fait de toute façon
la fin
il ya eu des personnes qui rue de
l'argent directement retirer leurs
contres donc tout ce que vous dites
c'est que c'est pas un problème de
décision la décision était bonne mais
elle a été mal présentée donc le choix
de la décision il fallait s'intéresser
sur l'interrogé sur les conséquences
mais ce qu'est ce qui a causé mais la
confusion et malheureusement je crains
durablement c'est la mauvaise
présentation d'abord parce que c'est pas
leur groupe qui décidez de fonctionner
leur groupe disait nous prêterons 10
milliards si vous vous en trouvez 6 ou
5,8 et il demandait aux chiffres aux
chypriotes comment vous allez trouver
ses 5,8 la une des réponses a été
j'étais pas là une et on ne sait pas
comment ça s'est passé ça a été que tous
se sont mis d'accord y compris le
chypriote pour le fait qu'il y ait une
taxe dans ses derniers mots qu'ils
soient prélevés sur l'épargné des gens
qui avaient déposé en banque ça veut
dire même pas des chiffriers de tous
ceux qui avaient déposé y compris et on
sait pourquoi des déposants étrangers
qui ont en fait la plus grande masse et
pour des dépôts en chypre les russes
mais aussi des britanniques vous par les
problèmes de communication l'eurogroupe
qui a pris à l'unanimité cette décision
est dirigé par un nouveau président un
seuil et round exxon bloom un hollandais
un néerlandais est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils impriment de compétence de cet
homme dans la gestion de la crise
compétences j'en sais rien je les ai
rencontrés récemment je pense qu'il est
compétent mais il est très nouveau dans
la fonction et ont pris la fonction de
ministre des finances et je pense
honnêtement mais peut-être parce que
j'aime bien jean claude juncker que
l'expérience de jean claude juncker ont
été nécessaires étaient son prédécesseur
aurait certainement amener un peu plus
de bon sens dans la façon de gérer ce
dossier même si c'est un dossier
difficile et si chypre il faut quand
même le dire à nos anneaux à nos
auditeurs c'est que chypre n'est pas un
pays comme les autres dans la zone euro
d'un pays très particulier et si je
voulais être un peu méchant pour les
chypriotes je dirais que c'est une
grosse lessiveuse pour blanchiment est
un lieu de parler fiscal comme le disait
votre reportage est ce qu'aujourd'hui
quand même là il n'y a pas un problème
de confiance dans la zone euro est ce
que les les déposants partout ailleurs
dans la zone euro que ce soit par
progress en espagne en italie et
pourquoi pas même en france est ce que
aujourd'hui
peuvent ne pas avoir des doutes
raisonnablement sur le fait qu'ils vont
pouvoir conserver leur arme je pense que
les déposants ont effectivement des
doutes on à leur encontre il n'ya pas
dire que les déposants qui ont des
doutes et aussi des doutes au niveau
international sur le comportement de la
gouvernance de la zone euro qui peut
donner l'impression d'être très
chaotique c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
alors est-ce qu'ils ont raison d'avoir
créé des craintes je pense que
aujourd'hui la situation chypriote alors
je sais bien a dit pour la grèce se
reproduira pas mais les chiffres c'était
prévisible et je crois que tout ce qui
est condamnable c'est que notamment la
commission n'ait pas été plus vigilante
depuis plusieurs années sur ce qui se
passait à chypre je pense la situation
de chypre est unique en europe et donc
les a vus sur la grèce
oui mais elle était unique là elle est
une autre c'est une autre unicité parce
que c'est pas le même problème la grèce
est un problème de d'appauvrissement
totale du pays et de difficultés graves
durable qui tiennent à la situation
économique de la grèce là pour chypre
c'est le fait d'une
surdimensionnement de la borne qui fait
courir les risques parce que les banques
sont plus à la hauteur des risques
qu'ils prennent non pas les liquidités
nécessaires mais je crois que nos
concitoyens
peuvent avoir des doutes chacun peut
avoir des doutes je crois que
raisonnablement d'un étang prévisible le
risque de mise en cause des dépôts est
très faible et en tout cas les
procédures qui sont actuellement à
l'étude pour l'avenir doivent permettre
de garantir que ça ne puisse pas se
passer de cette manière risque d'un
double mais il existe comme moi jamais
exclu moi je sais que mon argent ou le
houleux le vôtre qui sur sur des comptes
en banque et passe sous nos matelas il
peut à un moment être prêt oui dans
l'hypothèse où on est en train de mettre
en place des principes de résolution des
crises bancaires pour éviter qu'elles
n'atteignent ces dégâts et donc
l'objectif de ces mesures qui sont
prises au niveau européen est évidemment
de permettre qu'il n'y ait pas faire en
sorte qu'ils aient pas de crise bancaire
mais l'autre aspect c'est s'il y avait
une crise bancaire on veut préserver les
contribuables
c'est une volonté politique est donc
entre la banque et des contribuables
entre temps il ya les actionnaires de la
banque qui doivent être en première
ligne en cas de responsabilité
financière et puis il y a éventuellement
les déposant au travers de deux clauses
qu'on appelle les b line c'est à dire
des possibilités de ne rembourser qu'une
partie des sommes qui sont là si la
banque qui est en grande difficulté mais
je crois que cette situation peut être
exclue aujourd'hui dans des pays comme
la france des pays bas même l'italie et
l'espagne regardez le redressement les
mesures de redressement n'est ce pas ils
sont passés sans mise en cause des
dépôts des épargnants jean paul gauzès
dernière question sur l'avenir chypre
aujourd'hui va être renflouée l'europe
va lui prêter dix milliards d'euros est
ce que dans deux mois on va pas se
retrouver tous les deux l'un en face de
l'autre en train de parler de nouveau le
chiffre parce que de toute façon chypre
ne pourra pas rembourser
je crois que
on l'a vu pour la grèce bien souvent on
fait des calendriers les gens qui
réfléchissent peut-être passé font des
calendriers qui sont pas cohérents avec
la réalité pour lâcher pour la grèce où
j'étais de ceux qui pensaient qu'il
fallait faire une restructuration
immédiate à l'époque on disait qu'on
était foot ça ne serait jamais s est
faite elle s'est faite plus tard ça
coûtait plus cher pour chypre on a tardé
là on prend des mesures fortes mais
effectivement le risque existe que par
l'effet des conséquences économiques sur
sur chypre et notamment par une
disparition de l'activité bancaire ou de
certaines activités bancaires la
situation de chypre surply chromite
deviennent plus mauvaise merci beaucoup
jean paul gauzès d'avoir accepté notre
invitation on va rester sur chypre parce
qu'évidemment les télévisions
européennes en ont beaucoup parlé nous
allons recevoir christian spillmann qui
est journaliste de l'afp ici à bruxelles
mais tout d'abord je vous propose de
regarder ce zapping des télévisions
européennes
il est signé aurélie d'afas
chypre fait paillis et appelle à l'aide
le président chypriote et les bailleurs
de fonds entame alors des tractations
qui aboutissent dans la douleur
une journée marathon de négociations a
permis de boucler l'accord de sauvetage
par lequel chypre va commencer à
recevoir son aide de 10 milliards
d'euros à partir du mois de mai 2009 en
contrepartie notamment de la liquidation
de la banque liquide
la faillite et éviter mais à quel prix
la décision laisse un goût amer au
président du parlement chypriote puis je
suis
cette décision est douloureuse pour les
chypriotes super bowl
cette décision en effet une défaite de
la solidarité sur le balbuzard sochaux
et de la cohésion sociale une jeune
femme parlant d' appeler sont des
libertés fondamentales
on va et des principes fondamentaux de
l'union européenne ue
les réactions populaires explose sur les
écrans européens inquiétudes et
pessimisme de mon chemin je suis très
inquiète en effet
pour quelles raisons
pour notre vie à chypre pour nos enfants
pour le futur c'est une période très
difficile à traverser
alors voilà pour ce traitement de la
sphère chypriote sur les télévisions
européennes toutes les télévisions
européennes qui ont fait leur une là
dessus et qui continuent d'ailleurs nous
sommes avec christian spillmann bonjour
bonjour vous êtes correspondant de
l'agencé france presse de l'agencé
france presse afp ici à bruxelles vous
couvrez les affaires européennes depuis
20 ans
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire est ce qu'on
peut dire que l'europe a fait une erreur
monumentale avec chypre une erreur de
communication ça c'est certain je crois
que c'est des gens qui ne savent
absolument pas communiquer qui n'est
absolument pas expliquer ce qu'ils sont
en train de faire je crois qu'ils ont
fait une erreur de jeunesse avec sans
doute
un peu de fébrilité de la part du
président de l'eurogroupe qui s'est
retrouvé à succéder à jean claude
juncker le
luxembourgeois est un vieux crocodile
roues et toutes ces négociations
là on nous a mis un jeune néerlandais
qui est tout à fait compétence à fait
extraordinaire de voir qu'avec sa
candeur il nous a annoncé que dans la
grande interview qui a semé la
perturbation sur toutes les places
financières hier il a reconnu qu'il
n'avait pas compris le mot template ce
qui voulait dire modèle il dit moi je ne
connaissais pas assez vrai que c'est un
c'est pas un vrai mot qu'on utilise dans
le jargon
il a donné une interview au financial
times sont des gens que ce qui avait été
fait pour chypre vous pouvez
éventuellement servir de modèle pour les
résolution des crises dans d'autres pays
c'est bien ça absolument il a laissé
comprendre que c'était ça c'est en fait
ce qu'il voulait expliquer aux
contribuables et aux citoyens de l'union
européenne c'est que la règle c'était
qu'on allait plus payer quand tu nous
manques faisait faillite et ça tout le
monde peut le comprendre moi je suis
contribuable je suis ravi de savoir que
si jamais tel ou telle banque de tel ou
tel endroit de l'espace européen fait
faillite je vais pas être appelée à
contribution donc on explique
effectivement les gens qui sont dans les
banques qui font de l'argent en plaçant
leur argent dans les banques vont payer
ça c'est ça qui voulait lire et c'est ça
que la commission est en train de faire
sauf que effectivement son message est
absolument pas placé parce que ils n'ont
pas expliqué est ce que vous comprenez
la la je dirais sur le plan un peu plus
journalistique puisque vous êtes
journaliste il ya certains ont laissé
penser qu'il pouvait y avoir un risque
de contagion des ce qu'on appelle un
bank run donc c'est à dire une panique
bancaire dans d'autres pays que chypre
est ce que vous comprenez ça moi ce que
je comprends c'est qu'avec les
déclarations qui ont été faites hier
dans toute la zone sud de l'union
européenne que ce soit l'espagne
l'italie le portugal on se demande
maintenant si on peut laisser son argent
dans les banques et donc je pense que
les dirigeants seraient fort avisée
d'expliquer aux gens que non que vous
pouvez laisser vos dépôts que vous
économies sont protégées qu'elles vont
pas servir à combler tel ou tel trou
c'est ça le vrai message qui doivent
passer et ensuite expliqué ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire avec des banques
qu'on essaie de stable 10 c'est ce qu'a
tenté de faire je crois un peu françois
hollande lorsqu'il recevait cette
semaine mariano rajoy à l'elysée il a
dit que les dépôts de garantie était
quelque chose ok donc on ne pouvait pas
toucher selon vous c'est pas suffisant
il faut aller plus loin dans le fait de
rassurer les déposants européen je sais
que les gens n'y croient plus vous leur
annoncer que effectivement tous les
dépôts jusqu'à 100000 euros sont
garantis et puis tout d'un coup vous
découvrez que l'on fait une négociation
avec 17 mai de 17 ministres des finances
que vous avez un des participants en
l'occurrence les dirigeants chypriotes
qui ont accepté de taxer ces dépôts là
et que tout d'un coup on a accepté ça
alors qu'on aurait dû dire nous pas
possible donc aujourd'hui les gens ont
eu peur nous ne me crois pas
personnellement je pense que beaucoup de
citoyens de l'union européenne n'ont
plus confiance aujourd'hui et c'est
dramatique j'ai envie de vous poser la
même question que je posais tout à
l'heure à jean paul gauzès est-ce qu'on
va reparler de chypre dans les mois qui
viennent
je suis pas certain qu'on va reparler de
chypre ou même s'il ya beaucoup de
problèmes puisque je crois que voilà un
état de l'union européenne qui avait un
modèle économique et qu'il va falloir
qu'il l'aurait apprennent qu'il va
falloir les aider à faire quelque chose
d'autre donc on ne sait pas très bien
comment l'économie de chypre va pouvoir
se retourner comme on les cypriotes vont
pouvoir vivre à nouveau normalement non
je moi ce que je crains c'est que
malheureusement dans l'union européenne
on et d'autres problèmes qui se posent
d'ailleurs qui vont réclamer cela soit
en italique c'est ce qu'ont slovénie et
même dans des pays qui frappent à la
porte de la zone euro et on se demande
si vraiment ces pays sont aptes à
rentrer à intégrer cet espace de 17 pays
qui ont la monnaie l'euro comme monnaie
mais commune christian spillmann merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
on va reste évidemment en europe on part
en irlande il ya quelques mois une femme
était morte parce qu'elle n'avait pas pu
apporter nous avons voulu savoir quelle
était la situation de l'avortement là
bas dans ce pays nous allons retrouver
ensuite kathia gilder et son avis thème
est tout de suite direction l'irlande
avec ce reportage signé flora sauvage
fait divers tragique une femme enceinte
de 31 ans meurt après avoir demandé un
avortement qui lui a été refusée
automne 2012 après le décès de sa vita à
la pana var le débat sur l'avortement
est relancé en irlande ce fait divers
dramatique suscite un tollé général dans
le pays où ivg reste interdite après 5
référendum ce n'est pas la première fois
que la question revient sur le devant de
la scène
nay albiran dirige le planning familial
ici on milite en faveur de la levée de
l'interdiction de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse est maintenant
en 1983 un amendement dans la
constitution introduit l'idée que la vie
de la mère et celle de son bébé ont la
même valeur
depuis il n'y a pas eu de loi pour
préciser ce que cela signifie réellement
il a fallu un drame en 1992 pour
remettre en question cet amendement une
adolescente de 14 ans tombée enceinte
après un viol à qui on avait refusé un
avortement a conduit la cour suprême à
se prononcer deux des travaux on a eu
une interprétation de la cour suprême en
qui dit que si la vie de la mère est en
danger un avortement est envisageable
mais la difficulté c'est qu'aucune
législation n'a été mise en place aucune
consigne n'a été donnée au corps médical
si bien qu'aujourd'hui encore recourir à
une ivg est passible de la réclusion à
perpétuité
chaque année 5000 irlandaises vont à
l'étranger pour se faire avorter en
trente ans près de cent cinquante mille
femmes ont fait le voyage
car en irlande le poids de l'église a
toujours empêché les évolutions en la
matière les catholiques restent
farouchement opposés à l'avortement cole
qui a
non à dieu donne la vie et personne n'a
le pouvoir d' ôter la vie à part du
jazz be donc je ne pense pas qu'on ait
la liberté d'avorter non
sublet un enfant je suis fatigué
d'entendre ce qui se sont accros mêmes
libéraux ils ont perdu la foi
dans de très très très très très rares
cas d'accord mais en dehors de ça non ça
va à l'encontre de la loi de dieu de la
loi de la nature
en 2010 la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a condamné l'irlande à cause du
flou juridique qui entoure l'avortement
sous la pression internationale le
gouvernement s'est engagé à déposer un
projet de loi avant l'été une décision
saluée par sept députés de gauche elle
milite en faveur de la libéralisation de
l'avortement
le gouvernement a traîné des pieds
depuis des années sur cette question
c'est tout à fait historique même si ça
ne concerne qu'un petit nombre de femmes
symboliquement c'est très important car
ça veut dire que pour la première fois
en irlande nous allons avoir une loi sur
l'avortement
et c'est pour cette raison que les
opposants sont si énervé qu'il manifeste
tant est qu'il met autant d'argent pour
des campagnes de publicité financée par
les états unis
car en irlande les lobbys pro vie sont
très influents pour les opposants à
l'avortement le foetus est un être
humain dès les premiers instants de la
vie evelyne travail au sein de
l'association prélève campaign elle a
participé aux manifestations anti
avortement de ces derniers mois la
raison pour laquelle l'avortement est
une question qui pose problème c'est
qu'il y a deux vies en jeu il y a deux
corps
ce n'est pas que ma vie qui est en jeu
c'est aussi l'avis de mon bébé donc les
deux doivent être protégés
et cette vision est relayée au parlement
par le sénateur melaine
l'opposition à l'avortement en irlande
est souvent présentée comme une question
exclusivement religieuse dans une
société plurielle on ne peut pas
légiférer à partir de la foi de certains
mais c'est une mauvaise compréhension de
notre position la façon dont je vois les
choses que oui bien sûr on est inspiré
par la foi mais cela relève du bon sens
un instinct naturel de protection des
droits de l'homme
mais les mentalités évoluent la jeunesse
est plus ouverte sur la question même si
l'avortement sans motif apparent n'est
pas encore à l'ordre du jour
peut-être que les vieux se rencontrent
mais pas la génération de nos parents
je pense que ça devrait être légalisé
car c'est le corps de la femme la
décision doit lui appartenir et de toute
façon dans quelques années je pense que
ça sera légal alors pourquoi pas
maintenant
je ne suis pas d'accord avec elle car il
s'agit d'une vie à l'intérieur de soi
je dis ça maintenant mais si jamais je
tombais ensemble dans six mois je serai
peut-être la première allait apporter
alors je ne sais pas
malgré le déclin de l'influencé de
l'église catholique en irlande les
esprits évoluent lentement d'après un
sondage 85% des irlandais sont
favorables à l'avortement si la vie de
la mère est en danger seuls 36% des
personnes interrogées se prononcent pour
la légalisation de l'ivg et g quelles
que soient les raisons
une enquête tourné à dublin en irlande
par floral sauvage nous sommes revenus à
bruxelles avec nous sur ce plateau marc
tarabella bonjour bonjour merci d'être
là vous êtes député européen d'origine
belge et grand défenseur des droits de
la femme et de la cause féminine une
première question peut-être sur ce
reportage est ce que ça vous choque
qu'un tel drame ce décès de savita à la
pana var morte sans possibilité
d'avorter est ce que ça vous choque
qu'un tel drame survienne dans un pays
qui est actuellement président de
l'union européenne oui c'est choquant
parce que c'est la résultante qu'on le
veuille ou non d'un obscurantisme
religieux qui sévit encore en irlande et
cette pauvre savita devait faire elle a
fait une fausse couche et on a refusé de
l'avorter alors que l'enfant était plus
les têtes plus envie ou nallet serait
plus en vie et elle a souffert de
septicémie et elle en est décédé est
donc clairement au moins pour les
raisons médicales évidente cet
avortement devait être opéré il ne l'a
pas été et ça a coûté une vie d'une
jeune femme est clairement qu'ils
avaient envie de donner donner la vie
c'est tout salon des raisons médicales
mais clairement la situation évolue dans
le bon sens mais elle évolue lentement
en irlande qui reste un des deux pays de
l'union européenne où l'avortement est
illégal avait à malte alors
effectivement ce droit à l'avortement
n'est pas reconnue partout en europe et
ce que vous observez vous un retour en
arrière dans certains pays qui
autorisent aujourd'hui l'avortement par
exemple en espagne ce que vous observez
certaines pratiques plus ou moins
insidieuse qui tendrait à remettre
ce droit il faut se méfier des retours
en arrière car effectivement dans
plusieurs pays a des velléités de
changer les lois est d'ailleurs la
principale île natale l'espagne
notamment b le mouvement pro life sont
actifs dans toute une série de pays et
voudrait qu'on revienne en arrière sur
les lois qui ont autorisé lives et g et
donc on n'est pas garanti je dirais une
fois que la loi est votée
d'une part qui est pas le retour en
arrière car certains le veulent et
deuxièmement sur le terrain il faut se
méfier aussi dans la pratique de
l'accessibilité de la réduction
d'accessibilité de la femme à pouvoir
faire une interruption volontaire de
grossesse quand elles le souhaitent
pourquoi parce qu'il ya des hôpitaux qui
ferment parce qu'il ya une pression
sociale certains hôpitaux ne veulent pas
le faire certains médecins qui objecte
finalement le cas de conscience refuse
de le faire et il ya des difficultés y
compris en belgique
à cet égard là il ya des différences de
situation selon les pays puisque donc
l'avortement n'est pas un droit partout
en europe est ce que vous pensez qu'il
existe une frontière entre une ligne de
fracture même entre deux europes lui
vraiment un peu permissive est plutôt
libérale sur ce type de questions et
l'autre est conservatrice et
moralisatrice est ce que vous sentez une
fracture nette jeux sont nets non parce
que 25 pays sur 27 l'ont légalisé donc
c'est quand même une large majorité qui
reste petit pays qui doivent le faire
est clairement je sens aussi une
évolution même au sein du parlement
européen il ya trois ans j'ai fait
réinscrire dans un texte le droit à la
femme à disposer de son corps et à
pouvoir avoir un accès aisé à la
contraception à l'avortement il ya huit
ans que cela n'était pas acceptée
maintenant ça l'est parce que le
parlement européen s'est féminisé 35%
des élus sont des femmes et il est
rajeunie et que les jeunes générations
un petit peu comme dans leurs reportages
des jeunes générations de députés comme
les jeunes générations de citoyens sont
beaucoup plus ouverts sur la question
est y compris dans des groupes dans le
groupe chrétien démocrate qui est
souvent plus réticents cela souffle et
les français qui ont la loi la loi mais
il a quand même ils sont évidemment eu
favorable avec quelques autres mais même
dans des pays de l'europe centrale de
l'europe de l'est et même temps à malte
par exemple qui interdit formellement la
retenant vous êtes entendu aussi part
aux collègues de malte très
difficilement mais les collègues maltais
de mon groupe ont voté cette ce texte
donc clairement il ya une évolution
j'irai dans le bon sens y compris au
niveau des élus au delà de toutes
considérations religieuses ou morales
est ce que vous trouvez que le niveau
d'information et de connaissance sur
l'avortement est suffisant en europe
pour permettre aux femmes confrontées à
un choix quand elles le peuvent de
choisir en conséquence de cause ce que
vous pensez que les femmes sont sont
assez informés non il n'ya pas
d'éducation
affective et sexuelle correctement donné
dans le cursus scolaire à l'adolescence
dont généralement selon les pays
d'europe y en a où ça c'est rien à vous
ça se fait pas deuxième chose le centre
de planning familial sont très utiles
pour conseiller ils doivent être
accessibles ils ne sont pas répandus et
cela aussi est les différences selon les
pays donc évidemment on peut toujours
faire mieux en terme d'information je le
pense alors une autre question qui
concerne sur cette question du droit des
femmes à disposer d'elle-même c'est
celui de droit de prendre une
contraception est actuellement on parle
beaucoup des pilules contraceptives
notamment de 3e et 4e génération dont
certaines auraient provoqué des décès
c'est en tout cas les chiffres de l'
agence nationale française du médicament
qui dans son rapport estime que la
pilule contraceptive a provoqué 20 décès
sur les dernières années est ce que pour
vous ces pilules la présente des dangers
pour la santé quel niveau d'information
vous en tant que député européen vous
avez moi j'ai souhaité quand le débat
sur la pilule de 3e et 4e génération a
surgi c'est qu'il ya une information
claire de la part des fabricants de ce
type de contraceptif c'est qu'il sait
qu'il dise clairement de quelle
génération est la pilule puisque le
risque notamment d'avoir consulté des
avc et doubler selon la génération des
pilules si lille reste infime tout de
même et puis peut-être faut-il aussi
au niveau des prescripteurs de
contraceptifs peut-être avoir recourt
aussi à d'autres moyens je pense
notamment au stérilet qui peut être
efficace dans certains cas et quand il
ya un risque avéré
peut-être ou en tout cas plus importants
chez certaines femmes c'était de se
diriger vers un autre moyen de
contraception
on a parfois l'impression que les
prescripteurs vont très volontiers vers
ce qui peut apparaître comme le seul
moyen moderne de contraception est ce
que les laboratoires pharmaceutiques ont
aussi une responsabilité dans cette
affaire
oui en somme d'informations
information là aussi c'est maintenant
une trop d'info tué l'info on est bien
au courant mais à partir du moment
l'information a été donnée et que les
pilules de dernière génération troisième
et quatrième avec comporter un risque
plus élevé autant mettre sur la boîte
que de quelle génération et la pilule
qui est prescrit merci beaucoup marc
tarabella d'avant était avec nous sur ce
plateau c'est la fin de cette émission
se retrouve dans deux semaines à
bruxelles avec françois vos données très
bonne fille de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires